hello and good morning good afternoon
good evening wherever you are i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message today's december 6th 2021 we are
live streaming on rumble on youtube and
at blaze tv do me a favor if you're
watching on rumble make sure you
subscribe to our channel
there may be more rumble in our future
intent things are happening people uh we
got four stories for you i hope you had
a great weekend hope you didn't do too
much politics this weekend as you know i
try not to tweet on the weekends i try
to stay off the news so mondays i always
feel very refreshed and ready to go i
actually fell asleep guys believe it or
not i fell asleep at about nine o'clock
last night on the couch
felt good i feel refreshed and ready to
roll ready to roll give you
a big show today big show uh first up
kamala harris you know this kamala
harris woman she's the vice president
pulled at zero in the democrat primary
when she was running and then they
brought her in to one day replace joe
biden nobody likes her her staff is
dropping like flies and there's all
sorts of stuff breaking in mainstream
media now where they're starting to say
oh she's a bad boss
people don't like her she seems
unprepared etc etc and it's sort of
interesting that it's breaking in
mainstream because things only break
mainstream for a reason when they get
through that airlock and it's like why
is this happening is somehow the biden
people are they throwing her under the
bus somehow so we'll have some info on
that then the big story of course in the
media last week was chris cuomo
the journalist the actor
over at cnn who for a year and a half
was running cover for his brother andrew
cuomo governor of new york as he was
killing people and also sexually
assaulting women
they finally fired chris cuomo over at
cnn and then on stelter's show you know
this potato guy brian stelter on his
sunday show yesterday which is the most
ironically titled show in the history of
television called reliable sources they
actually started becoming self-aware and
asking maybe does this mean we've done
some wrong things at cnn how does this
reflect on us stealth didn't really get
it but one of the panelists kind of did
so we'll show you that then there's this
maniac this true
maniac and i was calling him a maniac
years ago i was ahead of the curve on
this one this guy bill de blasio he is
the outgoing mayor of new york city he
is a marxist he is a true authoritarian
lunatic and even though he only has
weeks left in his administration
he is now pushing for
uh mandates and for private companies to
be forced in effect to fire their
employees who are not uh man vaccinated
by december 27th i believe the guy is a
complete nut bag and you may be saying
dave why are you
showing us this video why are you going
to talk about this story we thought you
only do positive coveted stories but
i've got a twist on it and you'll have
to stay tuned because i've got a twist
that i think you'll find as a positive
twist oh and finally there's a male
uh swimmer who's winning all the female
records because you know feminism and
trans stuff because it's 20 21. so all
that and maybe more today on the reuben
report let's start with this kamala
harris story if you don't know kamala
harris well we put together this great
compilation video some of her best hits
[Applause]
so that's pretty much all you need to
know about kamal harris in terms of her
philosophy and political thought and all
that well now it's coming out that a lot
of people don't like her and in her wing
over at the white house there's a lot of
tumult and people are resigning all
sorts of bad stuff we've got some info
here from the daily wire in the midst of
frequent stories currently circulating
about the unhappiness of staffers
working for vice president kamala harris
one disenchanted former staffer for
harris harshly criticized her telling
the washington post it's clear that
you're not working with somebody who's
willing to do the prep and the work the
staffer continued with kamala you have
to put up with a constant amount of
soul-destroying criticism
and her own lack of confidence so you're
constantly sort of propping up a bully
and it's not really clear why
gil duran a former harris aide who
worked for her in 2013 for five months
before quitting echoed to the post one
of the things we've said in our little
text groups among each other is what the
common denominator through all this and
it's her who are the next talented
people you're going to bring in and burn
through and then have them pretend
they're retiring for positive reasons
according to one report concerned about
being permanently branded a harris
person is one of the reasons staffers
are considering leaving harris as they
don't want to be seen as being aligned
with her in case another democratic
candidate decides to run
for the democratic presidential
nomination in 2024 the daily wire
reported last thursday two more staffers
are reportedly
joining a growing exodus out of vice
president kamal harris's office less
than a year into her tenure let's just
show that video of her again
[Applause]
imagine if i was doing that all day long
and you guys worked with me like would
you you have to get another job you
can't blame any of these
okay
look nobody really likes her she was
brought in obviously it was sort of a
diversity hire they said we needed a
black woman or something
because joe is old and white and has
been in politics forever she you know
was the attorney general or something in
california was she attorney general or
is that what she was in california i
think she was attorney general um you
know and also it was a senator obviously
in california um but nobody likes her
nobody knows what she's about she's
deeply inauthentic and all that and the
reason i wanted to do this story was not
really because it's so enlightening to
say to you that nobody really likes
kamala harris or there's weirdness in
the white house what's interesting to me
about this is the airlock thing that i
mentioned a few minutes ago which is
that it's funny that suddenly all of
mainstream media washington post new
york post some of the other papers cnn's
now touching a little bit are starting
to uh discuss
what's wrong in her side of the white
house like that people are unhappy and
everything and it's like they don't they
coordinate all of this stuff you guys
know that they coordinate all of these
stories so suddenly that all of these
stories are leaking that something's
going on with kamala like that i don't
know what that is exactly but to me it's
something like the biden administration
is telling
the media people oh you can kind of run
with this like they want to kind of
sandbag her either because they know
that biden is not going to make it for
the four years right like because
obviously something ain't right there
and they want to figure out maybe they
don't they can't control her as much as
they thought they could control her or
something like that or they want to back
somebody else or who the hell knows but
that's the part that i find interesting
when suddenly the media starts showing
you a bunch of stories about something
it's very rarely really about the thing
that they're pointing at uh to be clear
she was attorney general of california
from 2011 to 2017 and she was senator uh
from california from 2017 to 2021 when
she obviously stepped down to become the
vice president anyway she's not well
mentally i would say and you know what
yeah one more time
[Applause]
i've known crack addicts that are more
stable than that one uh guys before we
move on i want to talk to you about
raycon you know by now you've probably
seen about a thousand gift guides for
the holiday season gifts for moms gifts
for guys gifts for your favorite
podcasters named dave you could study
all those gift guides and shop at 10
different places or you could start your
shopping at raycon and get a gift
everyone will use raycon wireless
earbuds whether i'm listening to them
when i'm doing my daily cardio or have
them with me on the plane when i'm
flying to an event i like to keep my
recons close raycons give you amazing
audio quality wherever you go whether
you use them to pump up wind down to
work or work out they'd be useful for
anyone on your gift list even better for
you they start at half the price of
other premium audio brands with their
latest model you get three new sound
profiles to make sure everything you're
listening to sounds it's best with just
the right amount of bass set them to
balance mode when you're catching up on
episodes of the reuben report raycons
are available in five stylish colors so
you can pick a perfect one for everyone
on your list with free shipping and
returns gifting is easier than ever the
holidays are coming up fast so join us
and go to
raycon.com
where my listeners are going to get 15
off site-wide uh it's
dot com by
reuben not raycon.com buy
raycon.com
reuben use code holiday to get 15 off
your entire raycon order by raycon.com
reuben and now back to me all right so
as i said the big story in the media
world last week was chris cuomo the
actor pretending to be a journalist who
was on prime time over at cnn uh he was
fired finally uh this was not an act of
cancel culture you know it was funny i
was thinking about it over the weekend
it's like we have so many people who get
fired or lose their jobs unjustly right
because of cancer culture this is a rare
example of a guy getting fired for the
right reasons like he was in complete
dereliction of his duty as a journalist
he was altering and somewhat hiding
stories there's evidence of it because
they were related to his brother and
info that he didn't want to get out
there so he's he's fully justified her
cnn is fully justified in their firing
of him but what's been interesting about
this is that uh cnn is almost sorta
kinda could they be maybe looking in the
mirror does stelter have a mirror we
know he doesn't have a scale but maybe
he has a mirror uh he did a segment
on uh the the cuomo firing and how that
reflects on cnn you know the biggest
media story this weekend it's the firing
of chris cuomo from this network cnn now
i've been working the phones ever since
this was announced yesterday
evening
frankly i've been on the phone to the
last five minutes here getting
information about what happened and
where cnn goes from here ultimately this
is about trusted media as sarah was
referring to trusted media has cnn lost
trust as a result of this eurowick
well you know i don't know that's hard
to say if cnn has lost trust here's the
problem we've really lost sense of media
ethics in our profession especially in
the last few years you have to ask
yourself first and this is the mistake
that chris cuomo made and in some sense
i think cnn made this same mistake and
not forcing him nasa's who do you work
for who do you serve
obviously you serve and you work for
your employer or you don't get a check
but beyond that
where who are you talking to you should
be serving the public so that's the
thing
i think this is a once in a lifetime
ethical dilemma that doesn't let's try
to let everything about the hook but
there's never going to be another moment
like this where there's a brother
there's an anchorman of a governor in
the middle of covid and you know one of
them gets covey like this was a
once-in-a-lifetime situation that
doesn't mean that everyone knows i did
the right things at the right time but
it was unique
all right so first off credit where
credit is due i will give stelter a
little credit for even doing this
segment right just
i'll get to what he said there at the
end where he you know sort of moves the
goal posts on it but like just for doing
the segment i'll give the guy like a
certain amount of credit the guest there
made a good point uh that media ethics
have been completely trampled on there
basically are no media ethics anymore um
i can tell you this that at this point
and i did one of these last week when a
mainstream publication reaches out to me
which they reach out to me several times
a week to get
they want quotes from me or they maybe
want to do a story on me or they want to
do a story on a friend of mine i almost
always know it's a hit piece almost
always and usually i just write back
something like you are not a journalist
you're an activist or you know something
to that effect and i say you can put
that on the record and then they don't
pretend print anything so i will give
stelter a little bit of credit there and
i'll also give the guest a credit for
saying hey we've failed we in the media
have failed because so many of us right
you guys watching this you know how
badly they felt now what's interesting
and this is where stelter fails is he's
asking the question like oh did have we
harmed our trust like have we not been
acting as good as we should have and
it's like well hey that's obvious right
like that's just obvious but like if you
just went through the list of things
that cnn has lied about over the last
say three years that is far
far bigger than chris cuomo who will
just be a footnote irrelevant piece of
history right they lied about brett
kavanaugh being a serial rapist remember
that was every single day on cnn 24
hours a day they lied about jesse smilet
being lynched remember that and now
they're not even really covering the
trial of jesse smilet right now because
it would expose all their lies in the
first place which is another type of
fake news the type of fake news is when
you promote a lying story but then
another type of fake news is when you
won't cover something because it also
goes against your narrative so that's a
double lie on smolette they lied
endlessly about the russia hoax
endlessly they lied about hunter biden
and the laptop and we weren't allowed to
talk about it they lied about the
covington kids being racist and then uh
who's who's the kid the main kid the
main covington kid
the maine covington kid
uh yo nick sam man thank you nick salman
won a big lawsuit against cnn because of
that they lied about uh kyle rittenhouse
they lied about the very fine people
hoax where trump did
condemn the white supremacists and the
neo-nazis so you guys have lied about
about like all of the stuff that has
mattered culturally in and politically
and you will continue to lie and we'll
know you're lying and you'll know you're
lying and yet you'll continue to lie
right well you know all that so this is
where stelter doesn't get credit because
it's like i'll give you credit you did a
segment you sort it like and he's been
on the phone a lot and my god okay fine
you did the segment you got called out
on media ethics which you don't have you
don't seem to be aware of all the other
things that you've lied about or that
you lie about by omission and then
finally there at the end when he's
trying to clean it up and he's like this
is this is a once-in-a-lifetime thing i
mean an anchor and his brother and a
pandemic well first off once in a
lifetime this pandemic's been going on
for two years so let's just remove this
pandemic has been going on for two years
let's just remove pandemic but the idea
of a brother reporting on his brother i
mean almost everyone at all of these
networks is either related to or a
cousin of or married to or a former
staffer of or something to someone that
used to be in an administration
somewhere george stephanopoulos the
chief
abc news correspondent with his sunday
show used to be a bill clinton staffer
right it's like we all know all of these
things the the people that uh fail in
government go on to all of these shows
and then they either protect their ass
from [ __ ] that they did before like you
get it you get like what a giant snake
eating circle jerk it is i think we all
get it uh so stelter i tried to give you
a little bit of credit there but i can't
give you that much credit anyway i don't
think we're gonna have to we'll have to
talk about this story anymore because
cuomo is gone and the point is that i
mentioned last week it's like he
deserved to go because of the the
dereliction of duty but also had they
brought him back it would have been like
wait a minute there are so many other
people out there that would kill for
that job and don't you people always
tell us how racist and homophobic the
world is and why wouldn't you hire a gay
black lesbian to do that job that would
be the best thing that you could do so
we hope
my hope is that cnn will live up to its
diversity and inclusion standards and
picked whoever is the most oppressed
journalist in the world we must find
that person what whoever is winning the
oppression olympics because of their
ableism or their disableism and the
color of their skin and their religion
and their sexuality and their gender
identity i want to he himself
like the full thing on cnn and that's
what i want
don lemon to throw to in the whatever
time that show is on 9 pm or something
like that anyway let's move on uh you
know my policy on covet guys and it's
it's tough to hold to this policy it's a
reuben report policy and i try to uh go
by the policies that i uh set forth here
at the reuben report my policy is i
don't want to put out the uh the stories
about kova that are going to depress you
because it's just like we just have to
move on and i think in most cases most
of you guys have moved on i have moved
on i don't wear a mask anywhere you've
got to live your life get injected 80
times whatever you want to do like make
some decisions for yourself this [ __ ]
ain't going away they love the power
they want more control over your life
okay we all get it well there's this guy
bill de blasio and he's he's a true
psychopath horrible mayor of new york
city destroyed new york city to the
point that my family i've mentioned this
many times before there were times since
around 1910 that my family had probably
at the height of it about 60 to 70
family members living in new york city
in the boroughs we got two left i used
to say there was one but i did uh i was
informed of a cousin in brooklyn i got
one in manhattan one in brooklyn
everyone else has fled my sister was the
last one to flee with her husband and
two kids during the pandemic the city is
dirty it's gross it smells like weed
crime is through the roof you can break
into stories and steals [ __ ] we all know
that you can just go into cvs and just
clear out an aisle nobody's going to do
anything it's really really depressing
it just it just is he ruined the
greatest city on earth that's what bill
de blasio did and you know hopefully
it'll come back at some point but
anyway the guy's got about three weeks
left of his uh his terrible
administration and uh listen to what
he's doing with his last couple weeks we
in new york city have decided to
use a preemptive strike to really do
something bold to stop
the further growth of covet and the
dangers it's causing to all of us so
as of today we're going to announce a
first in the nation measure our health
commissioner will announce a vaccine
mandate for private sector employers
across the board
all private sector employers in new york
city will be covered by this vaccine
mandate as of december 27th we're going
to have some other measures as well to
really focus on maximizing vaccination
quickly so we can get ahead of omicron
and all the other challenges we're
facing right now
okay so you get it he's a fear-mongering
maniac a head of omicron okay there's
about three people in the united states
with omicron which is from what i'm told
is no relation to unicron the
planet-eating destroyer from the
transformers movie in 1985 way better
than any of the michael bay transformers
movies by the way
um he's a maniac he is a complete maniac
so what is the part of this that is the
positive part well first the positive
part is he's leaving right this guy is a
couple weeks left and he's going out in
what he views i suppose as a blaze of
glory this is a guy who and he had
locked everybody down and said don't go
to the gyms he was caught at the gym he
was caught in the park i mean he's just
he's just a horrible human being like
that that's all i can say about these
people at this point like what else is
there to say about all of these people i
i don't know but the silver lining is
this
new yorkers
and i was there a couple weeks ago and i
spent most of my adult life living in
new york city i was i moved to new york
city right out of college about 2000 i
lived in new york city until about 2013
when i moved to this crazy dystopia of
los angeles i really should have my head
examined but
um
new yorkers have a sense of fight and a
sense of spirit if you if you haven't uh
watched the ghostbusters the original
ghostbusters movie or ghostbusters too
even you can really feel it in
ghostbusters if you don't believe me
that's new yorkers still have that when
i was there a few weeks ago you could
still feel that on the streets and i
think people have had it with this
[ __ ] i really do and i think a lot
of people are just going to say no no
i'm not complying i will not comply
i am not listening to you you are a
crazy communist nut bag you're on your
way out you people do not own our lives
we elected you
to well we elected you or we didn't vote
for you but somebody elected you to to
defend our rights not have you rule over
us like kings and queens and you're
horrible people and we're just not going
to do it and by the way when i was in
new york city that was when you had to
show the passports and all that and
nowhere was i asked to put uh to show a
passport i went into places without
masks and all that so
the silver lining is that the more they
get hysterical and that's what these
idiots are doing they are making omicron
into the next delta and there will be
something after that and something after
that and they will never they will never
look at themselves right they'll never
take that mirror de blasio said it right
there two years into this thing well
wait a minute two years into this thing
who was the mayor for two years it was
you you douchebag so maybe you should be
looking at your policies if it's so bad
and stepping down in shame rather than
pushing more draconian laws
but this has nothing to do with a virus
anymore as you know this is about crazy
people who want to control your life and
it will be your job on this planet earth
to make sure that they do not control
you so the positive twist again in case
you missed it there the positive twist
is that people will just ignore it i
really think that will happen even here
in this ridiculous place known as los
angeles i see people starting to ignore
it people will just ignore these people
they will keep coming out with more
ridiculous you know it's almost
you hear this out of communist regimes
that the the rhetoric keeps getting
ramped up and ramped up and ramped up
because they know they don't have the
people so they just have to keep seeming
like it's the show must go on you know i
talk about kayfabe a lot which is which
is wwe it's wrestling that we're all
watching this thing that we know isn't
true but we're all participating it and
you can have real emotions as hulk hogan
slams andre the giant and you can be
like oh my god hogan beat andre the
giant and you have this feeling like oh
my god that just happened in front of me
and it's real even though they set the
whole thing up beforehand and that's
sort of what we're in right now we're in
the show must go on version of democracy
with these clowns and i think more and
more people will just ignore it and go
about their lives and
and i i don't know beyond that i think
we still got a lot to fight but that
that's the hope the hope is that you're
the hope
and proof me right would you do me a
favor prove dave right okay story number
four uh there is a biologically
male swimmer who's mopping up in the
female division this is a trans female
so he was born a male he was a male
swimmer just a few years ago but he's
crushing it and breaking records in all
the female swimming competitions just as
the first wave feminist feminists would
have hoped for we've got a quote here
from the new york post
leah thomas a 22 year old transgender
swimmer at the university of
pennsylvania has been shattering records
at the school before her transition she
competed for three years at penn as a
man named will thomas do we have a
picture of will oh yeah there's will
right there look at that tall guy will
look at him i don't know who that little
guy is next to him but will's a big guy
and will is now a female swimmer good
for will it is unknown when thomas
transitioned from male to female but the
swimmer competed as a man as recently as
november 2019 ncaa rules mandate at
least one year of testosterone
suppression treatment to be eligible to
compete as a woman as is always the case
in stories like this there is a lot of
controversy about the fairness of people
who are born as men competing as women
this past june the department of justice
argued that laws in arkansas and west
virginia barring athletes who were born
as men from competing in women's sports
were unconstitutional that's some fine
work there by the department of justice
the united states has a significant
interest in ensuring that all students
including students who are transgender
can participate in an educational
environment free of unlawful
discrimination the doj said in court
documents filed in a west virginia court
and can we get those before and afters
again let's just see so
we've got him uh that's her now right
that's her now and that's her then so
very okay that's just fine now i want to
be very clear
want to be very clear i have no problem
with what a grown adult does with their
body and if you want to live life as the
other sex if you are trans if you want
to just dress up as a woman keep your
genitals
slice off your genitals add genitals
whatever you want to do
god bless you
i applaud you fantastic and again if you
respect me i'll respect you so i have
trans friends i know some trans people i
have no problem calling them by their uh
preferred pronouns etc but if you're
going to be like some crazed maniac
demanding i bow to you all the time
probably not going to do that now
do i have to add much more to this like
you guys get it this is a problem and
it's not just a problem because of the
failure of feminism so the the feminist
movement has gone from equality for all
let's have equality true equality for
women which we do have now
to now the feminist movement
is now promoting the idea that a
biologically born male should win all of
the awards in swimming as this person
transitions to a female and that they
are doing in the name of feminism and
equality it's so patently absurd that if
you wrote it in a book 20 years ago
people would have said you are crazy and
yet here we are also the fact that the
department of justice
is weighing in on this and basically
forcing
west virginia schools and some other
schools to have these people compete
in the gender class that they wish as
opposed to the one that they were born
in is just absolutely bananas you'd
think that the department of justice
might have some better things to do but
here we go
hank says uh the kamala clip on rumble i
haven't heard cackling like that since
keaton's batman pushed nicholson's joker
over the bell tower that's right that's
right i felt that my kamala cackle is a
little bit of jack nicholson's joker
and tk says can both cuomos be named
fired oh that's good that's good not
fredo fired oh that is good right there
uh all right guys uh my full interview
with brandon tatum former police officer
co-founder of blexit is up on youtube
and rumble right now i'll be
interviewing kaylee mcinerney former
white house chief of staff under
president trump i'm interviewing her
tomorrow and then i think it's going up
on
wednesday if i'm not mistaken and i'm
really looking forward to talking to her
i like her we've become friendly
but you know to juxtapose what that
woman what kaylee had to go through for
the years that she was white house press
secretary to compare that to jen saki
jensaki who's so unprepared lies about
absolutely everything with a press that
basically is like sucking her off the
entire time versus what kaylee had to
put up with with a press that wanted to
destroy her trying to transmit something
remotely true not that all press
secretaries are always telling the truth
obviously and i'll ask her about that
but like just trying to communicate when
you're the evil one to the press as
opposed to now when the press is rooting
for you uh if you want to chat along
during the shows you always can at
reubenreport.locals.com
and uh as i said some big things coming
should i send it through the pipes again
one more time guys some big things are
coming i think maybe a little
announcement next week i i'm pretty
consistent you know what i mean if i say
something's coming it's coming i don't
let you down so
there you go all right see you tomorrow